elle a atteint son but depuis trois ans
après plusieurs années de travail de
bureau ses six jurés a décidé de se
lancer s'installer tous les jours
derrière un volant était un rêve
elle travaille pour les cars périer
depuis 2010 est le fait de rendre
service aux gens qui est une motivation
que j'ai depuis depuis tellement
longtemps que j'ai sauté le pas pour le
concrétiser
le déclic c'est un changement de
situation professionnelle des rachats
successifs le tout cumulé a fait que je
me suis dit bon jeu depuis je voulais
faire ma formation et je vais sauter le
pas et j'ai fait ma formation est resté
à côté je voulais je vous dirai en face
et pas trop loin je vous dirais ou au
dessin vous en prie détourner du matin
détourné d'après midi cécile s'adapte
aux arrêts à ses passagers pour les cal
n hésite pas à être aux petits soins qui
jamais chez pas bien stationner vous
descendrez par la fin qui fait que c'est
important c'est les sur qui est
notamment les personnes les personnes
âgées qui ont du mal à ce qu'ils ont du
mal éventuellement à se déplacer donc ça
c'est pour moi c'est une
c'est très important c'est pour ça que
si j'ai des fois je n'hésite pas comme
des fois les arrêts ne sont pas
forcément des droits normalement on les
voyageurs doivent descendre par la porte
arrière
mais dans certains cas je n'hésite pas à
dire aux voyageurs si je vois qu'il est
un petit peu en difficulté de le faire
descendre par la porte avant présente
sur plusieurs lignes du réseau stibus
cécile a continué à assurer le transport
d'usagé lors du premier confinement le
fait d'être à l'extérieur comme camping
et nancy pas forcément maintenant je
n'aurai pas le choix je veux dire je
leur ai fait mais non j'ai souhaité je
souhaitais continuer travailler quand il
a été proposé le chômage de partiel moi
j'ai comme j'ai souhaité j'ai souhaité
continuer comme cécile 14 autres femmes
font partie de l'équipe de conducteurs
des cars périer
l'entreprise fait mine et son équipe
depuis 2013